I always get an aisle seat on a plane
and if I don't if I if I have to get a
window I'm like I feel bad for the
person at that point you sit down I
don't and then I'm just like you know
what they're an adult they can deal with
how many times
but you don't tell them to move you just
go like this yeah yeah on top of them
yeah and I kiss him on the forehead
random people you know sorry you know
you don't have to get up I gotta go pee
and this is my issue so let me just
climb on me like that it always is a
debate they're like should I get up or
should because then because it's so
funny to make an adult like do like that
and you do yeah you're like yeah do that
no don't get up yeah and they're like oh
I'm fine I'd rather get up actually I'd
rather get up and do this crazy move
yeah contort your body yeah for me to
squeeze bye